cette décision je crois elle était
attendue une décision attendue même aux
plus hautes instances la protection des
bélougas a eu raison de la construction
de ports pétroliers à cacouna
transcanada dit que c'est une question
de respect tout en refusant d'avouer
qu'elle en tire une leçon de la preuve
qu'on fait les choses correctement et on
est allé coûte à cacouna l'histoire se
répète c'est la troisième fois que
projet avorte à son port la mairesse ne
cache pas sa déception on a travaillé
très fort ce projet l'eau alors ce matin
cette annonce là aussi attendait mais on
avait toujours espoir bon peut-être que
ça il y aura des modifications auprès
des citoyens l'abandon du projet
continue de diviser
je pense que pour l'environnement on est
plus serein au final est ce qui peut
douter quelle démarche est fait pour que
le terminal soit construit ici au québec
à l'assemblée nationale la coalition
avenir québec reproche au premier
ministre de ne pas assister pour la
construction de ports pétroliers au
québec je voudrais rappeler à la
compagnie à l'entrepreneur qui doit
déterminer un projet s'il veut que son
projet soit étudié fait les couillard
ratèrent ces conditions hulot on va
assister sa figure dans les sept
éléments qu'on a publié au quai des
retombées économiques pour le québec
soit directe soit fiscale mais s'il ya
un projet qui parle par le québec il y
aura de retombées fiscales les emplois
que nous sommes à l'étude d'autres sites
potentiels pour un port maritime au
québec
transcanada a dans sa mire d'autres
sites au québec est la municipalité de
baie des sables près de matane et l'o2
les noms de lévis bécancour et de
l'ancienne raffinerie shell à montréal
circule aussi je pense vraiment de les
certitudes
c'est plate pour la population c'est
plate pour nous les élus parce que
depuis novembre
2014 qu'on entend parler qu'on est un
plan b pour transcanada on les a pas
encore rencontré transcanada souligne
que son projet final sera connu d'ici la
fin de l'année la mise en opération est
maintenant en 2020 au lieu de 2018 ici
zabel damphousse radio-canada rimouski